all right beautiful
hi welcome back hi how are you thanks
so how have you been things have uh it's
been six months or so since we saw you
last
yes are you still living on the street
um yes periodically
i've maintained a cute couple of
different people that are willing to let
me stay with them but
other than that it's the same thing
and it's winter time now so it's got to
be really rough cold
very easy this is california people
don't realize how cold it is it almost
feels like alaska right now it's just a
trip
but i'm hanging in there i'm maintaining
you're saying i've gained a little
weight but
you're still you're still working the
street yeah i'm figure out
yep and western yeah
what's going on with your kids and your
that's the interesting part um
apparently my daughter came out to visit
me from vegas
and i don't know who some people decided
to
rob her as she was leaving me
took her house keys together and she
didn't tell me she just kind of ran to a
friend of hers
and she called me when she tried to go
back home
her whole apartment's raided done they
wiped it out
her my grandbaby stuff's gone
it's a lot going on yeah i just it's
such a rough
neighborhood in a rough it's beyond it's
a rough lifestyle in a rough
neighborhood
and then you never know you run into or
who's listening or who knows how to get
information about you so
yeah and yeah you don't seem to like
like
well suited for that life you you seem
like you're not using graphics i don't
even do people wrong
right but you don't use drugs no which
is making sure it bothers me like
one of the very few right it's just
tripping me out like i'm thinking like
is it something from my past that i
don't know about
that's coming forward or
i don't know it's just weird i would
never think in a million years someone's
go to my kids
and hurt where they stay i could see
them coming
maybe burn up my tent or you know do
something to me
if they were angry but they went
directly to my daughter
so do you think i mean because of the
child abuse that you
experienced with your dad when you were
young do you think that
i'm i'm leading you on here but to me it
sounds like after hearing so many of
these stories
where women have been abused usually
sexually
by a step dad or a father or a cousin or
somebody
it almost like rewires your brain where
you can't accept good things in your
life and you end up making bad decisions
almost naturally well back then it did
me like that
because i got married early and i had a
oh my god amazing husband super square
um jehovah's witness family
i mean literally none of them got in
trouble ever so it was like weird
um so to maintain a straight face and be
cool
it was different so i kind of was in and
out the house all the time
i wasn't cheating but i just always seek
sanity somewhere else away from him
and my sanity actually was with him and
so he was a good guy oh my god amazing
yeah you were
attracted to something more destructive
i was attracted to the streets it wasn't
i wasn't cheating i wasn't trying to be
with anybody it was just the streets
that's what my outlet was when i got
molested when i was young
i'd hide in the closet i go outside and
play i just
go outside and that's always my outlet
and it
seemed like every time we had i had sex
with my husband
i'd have to go outside it was just like
weird i was trying to get myself to be
able to be with one person
and not think about what happened but at
that time
every time i got touched i felt like i
was nasty
i felt like i was just a little girl
again and i could always see and if
someone called me baby or
little girl or one word that's what i
felt and it would make me feel gross
and then i'd get up and go but when my
dad changed his life
and went he went to a
a posture school and he changed his life
like he's amazing now
he's 56 but i don't hold grudges
i can't make them feel guilty i'm not
going to because
throughout my pattern of life it took me
back and forth to jail
fighting abusive relationships
everything you could think about the i
went through it
and he topped it out with my mother and
my children and
my girls love them they they're like pop
is great and your relationship with him
now is good
um we barely talk but when we do us
relation to the kids or
if someone passes i see him uh the kids
frequently go see him
does he ever bring up what or do you
ever bring up whatever i will do it
i won't do it to him because he's
different he's
he's one example of a man who really can
change from being whatever it was when
the devil jumped on him
whatever that was that touched him at
that time
he's an example of a man who doesn't who
can excel change and do something
different and not pursue that
give that aura well it's great that you
can forgive him as well
oh yeah what do you think tell me
because your story is is pretty much the
blueprint for what happens with a lot of
women
that work the streets is is what
happened to you back when you were whole
like
eight nine i was six it started six six
years old
until you were like 13 i think and uh
what does that do to a woman when she
gets older
it kind of makes her promiscuous she
reaches out for men
to see if she could even be with one
it's kind of like you're trying to test
yourself to answer a question to you
am i able to be in a relationship am i
able to have a man
do i want to be touched kind of like
that
and i noticed most people like myself
we've had
multiple multiple multiple relationships
because you can't
just seem to grab your head around and
it seems like every time you get one it
always looks like the person that hurt
you
makes sense looks like what the person
that hurt you oh i see
and it's like you're going oh my god is
this really true like am i really doing
this
and it's it's i guess a shade a cloud
that you put over your eyes
and um i can't really say
it troubles me sometimes i have dreams
because i don't want to happen to my
daughters
so i'm just like what kind of guys are
these girls picking and now my 16 year
old daughter's pregnant
so i'm just like dude did you like
really step into my
pattern because i was 16 when i was
pregnant and i'm like oh
don't deal with god it's a pattern it's
just repeat it's like my life's already
pretty destined for me and it's already
written and
so the father of your 16 year old
daughter's
child is someone she's choosing to be
the father of
her child i assume so because i haven't
really got to see her i'm supposed to be
going out there to renovate to
be with them soon so um i asked her i
said what's up with this guy
she sent me a picture of him
he's not my idea he looks like a little
thug but um
she's pregnant so i told her i can't be
mad do you want it
she says i'm gonna have it mom we don't
kill babies we don't
that's something we don't do in our
family you lay down you get it you have
it
it's just simple there's no cut red say
with that
we don't we're not gonna kill no kids
there's no abortion there's none of that
in our life
so i told her do you want me out there
you need me and she's like
i do want you to come when the baby's
born i have to have that support
and i'm like freaking out because i'm
like i remember me and dude i hid it
from my mom and dad for eight and a half
months
i was almost due you know what i mean so
i just don't want her to be a hot butt
like me i don't want her to just let him
you know be that you're not a hump toy
you're not that let it be that for now
you know what i mean
raise the baby the best you can but
finish school and i'm gonna be there to
support her
to the best of my ability that's all i
can do that's great
how much does shame play a part in your
life after something like this happens
to a young girl
a great deal i call her every day i
can't stop calling her because it's like
if i was there i don't think it
necessarily would have happened
no no no i'm not talking so much about
your daughter you mean me in terms of
you and your
uh the trajectory your life took a lot
because um i tested drugs out before
i thought that was an outlet drove me
crazy um i had to sit back and chill
like it was just taking me from one
euphoric moment to the next
i'd call and bug the crap out of him and
my mom
i'd cuss my mama like why did you let
this happen to me like you're not a mom
you know i would just
you know obliterate the story and i'd go
on and on
about it and then when you go outside
you don't want to be seen like this kind
of stuff
i would never wear this i started
wearing like boy clothes baggy clothes
i i had a pretty nice shake i've always
had a little coca-cola bottle shape but
i didn't know i didn't want to be seen
and if i did my body was pretty too
people are cute to people i didn't want
that to be
no and i don't want to hear that if they
commented me no you know i mean don't
talk to me
you know i always had a shield my
defense mechanism is ridiculous
it's still ridiculous like i'm still by
myself
i don't choose to have anybody because
when i stop
doing this crap because i'm not i'm not
happy about this prostitution thing
at all um it makes me feel like um
i'm purpose purposely giving myself away
to just anybody because of what happened
to me or just for money i'm not like
that
i know i'm not i've had great jobs so i
know i'm work
ethic eligible like i know i can get
down yeah my question about shame though
was was basically the shame
from what happened to you with your dad
when you were young maybe led you into
doing this and now by doing this that
causes more shame and it's an endless
cycle of just
destruction because i you don't see me
outside much unless i really have to go
get something
yeah and doing this without drugs is
that difficult extremely
because i think the majority of the
girls are dropping out oh god extremely
difficult because like i said i
think harder i'm always a thinker and i
when i'm out there i
really don't just jump to every car that
pulls over
like i'm constantly reading people
because i don't want to get hurt
how many how many guys will you turn
down to try to pick you up a lot
a lot more turn downs than actually
getting that's why i can't have a pimp
i can't have someone that's going to try
to press me to make a quota
or nothing like that because i'm not
gonna make it i know i'm not
because i'm not gonna force myself to
just be with anybody for one you can't
just come home from work and try to be
with me i can't do it
you gotta shower and if i have a room
whoever i pick up if you're
if you don't you got to get my shower
like you're going to shower
i i'm very very very very can tell my
body
yeah i do i will not do do you respect
the guys that pick you up
of course i'm not gonna um do you like
them
no not all of them um
i treat them as people because i don't
want them to do me dirty while they're
while we're in the midst of whatever so
i try to make it as pleasurable as
possible
i don't look at people's tricks sorry
girls this is not my thing
um i have to put my mind in a different
set to even lay with
so yeah you'd have to do something huh
you would have to do something yeah
you're not getting drunk you you have to
either i have to really really psych my
mind out
disassociate or something huh you have
to disassociate or something
to really to ah that's why i'm always
doing something before i actually step
outside
like i'm all but but it still must be i
don't know where to use
you know it's got to affect your your
psyche your soul
your spirit yourself it does because
if my daughters or somebody caught me
outside walking the street
i would freak out i will play it off so
i'll be like
um you know i mean is it hard for a
working girl
that gets seen by one of your neighbors
or something sometimes i venture out
like figaro and western those are areas
that i don't mean i'm more like in
the valley and stuff that's where i
usually live at i just barely started
being homeless
out here this is just i try not to do
anything out here i'm more van nuys area
oh i see yeah so you stay away from
where you live
for that reason so that your friends and
family don't see you but then most of
them were starting to work
out here now so yeah well then my case
manager
actually um was driving down figaro one
day and saw me
and he pulls over he's like tell me
you're not
i go i'm not game face you know what i
mean yeah but now you're doing a video
on youtube
all right and i hope he never looks at
it but total gameplay i mean he pretty
much knows about me he's my case manager
i've had to
fill him in on a lot but it's weird to
even have a male case manager
i think people are very quick to forgive
somebody like yourself
because you're just trying to make ends
meet yeah but i don't do people dirty
either i'm not like some girls
if they don't want to do it if they
don't have sex they might just try to
take it i'm gonna do something i don't
like bad karma
i can't it's it's me versus
looking over my back to go in the
streets
and you're walking for hours it's not
like you go out there and boom
boom is there no you're walking for
hours so
nine times out of 10 you're looking
straight forward you're barely stopping
and you have certain rocks you take
familiar territory so the person that
you do wrong
they're not slow you know what i mean
you can you make yourself very early and
i don't want to be hurt so i don't want
to be vulnerable i'm not going to treat
anybody wrong
and it just is what it is so i get my
respect back the way i give it
yeah do you have regulars that take care
of you and i wish
i don't know how to keep them so i'm
still like i feel like i'm still
new to it because i i don't i don't like
it uh
i would think you'd be a prime candidate
for some guy to just think you're the
some of them do they all say that but i
mean i can't keep a consistent
phone no but but do you not have some
guys that just want to save you and all
that kind of stuff
i've heard it they don't they don't
follow through they don't follow through
yeah i also think it's more difficult
than just saving you
or getting you a car in an apartment i
think there's probably years of
of patience see i don't like to put my
hurts like if i get with someone new
i'm not gonna boggle their brain with my
past
because to boggle their brain is going
to get stuck and at some point you're
going to see behaviors
like they're kind of like if-ish
so i don't even want to put that in a
friendship or a client's
mindset or even someone who wants to be
with me i'm never ever going to tell
anybody again about my past even though
now we're broadcast radio but
you know i i don't want that to be a
pain factor to be talked about because
if i want people to want me for me
regardless
help me for me because i know what to do
with my money i'm not out here oh as
soon as i get married i'm going right
there
every time i get a certain amount of
money i send my daughter 50 because she
takes care of most of the
smaller kids so i send something to her
i have to
she's like the matriarch of the family
right now she took my position
so i have to look out for her and once i
do that
for her then i try to go get an outfit
or two because for some reason i can't
seem to get clothes
or shoes somebody's always on my
stuff it's like i feel like i'm being
followed like what's wrong here
um i got a lot of jealous people because
i don't do drugs
so i'm just different i'm always upbeat
moist minded if i can um
i try to stay out of the way
yeah i stay to myself pretty much but i
stays out the way i don't i don't
like drama i don't do arguing
i have seizures so for one i'm not gonna
let my brain get all that pressure
for two i always tell a partner of mine
or whatever
i'm not gonna argue with you so don't
think if i walk out the door
i'm gonna go be with someone else i'm
just walking out the door because i have
to breathe
and then i'm gonna come in back and
speak with you like a lady
because that's what i am and that's how
i have to live my life
i have to that's how come i don't have
as many battle wounds as these girls
like i look at some of these girls and
i'm like what is going on
what do you guys do and the girls with
the pimps oh my god
sometimes i wish i was one i'd be like
girls like come on like
you guys will not get hurt like you know
what i mean i would have a so different
type of
this life and it's getting worse oh my
god i mean
these girls like now they're totally
getting like young young girls because
they beat the crap out of these old
girls they're toothless they're
and i'm like whoa you know they use them
so they can't use them no more
and it's done and i feel bad for the
ones who only know
their pimp what are you gonna do when
you leave
um or when he leaves you well i think i
think it's difficult for a girl to get
out of that situation because she
doesn't
the reality of a life not doing that is
very scary
it takes a lot of courage for a girl to
get out it does because then you're
working on it
you need to like do what you need to get
get a regular way to support yourself
you need
to walk which is hard right and you got
to be willing to
step out i step outside the box anyways
and look for work ethic i'll go to temp
agencies and everything
i could see you i could see you making a
transition easier than anywhere baby you
don't know
so i mean if it if that opportunity
precedes itself i'm on it
i can't i'm just i'm unhappy with this
but i keep a smile it's all i can do
your attitude is great these are hard
times right now too
hard cold and um not very many people
are even wanting to give out money
so yeah so it affects every
every part of the uh the food chain
including
yes figaro is way worse it's like a
million girls and they're all harping at
the same thing
so no i i see very few girls down there
that are actually jumping into cars and
driving well now they're um
they say more they don't stay up by the
florence and figueroa area they try more
to venture down
because that's where more money is uh
different class of people
it's like they're from the 82nd
and up they're trying not to even deal
with
70s 60s because that's where all the
gangsters sat that's where all the pimps
are
the gangsters the pimps all that like
there's too much trickeration right now
i don't think we're ready for all that
and i mean it seems like we're um
flocked with people like where'd all
these people come from
i was like dude what is going on and
then they come
i mean nice cars you know but none of
they stop they look
next thing you know two seconds later
you see your guys come here baby like
okay now you want to free you know come
on
it's crazy i don't know
just let me learn right
you're living a crazy life and you you
definitely deserve better as all the
girls do
so many stories are heartbreaking
including yours yep
and i don't really know what the
solution is
patience well see i think a lot of the
girls just
are unable to accept what the change in
their you know to change their whole
life
change the path of their life entails i
think it's i've actually
been um you you've lived a straight line
yeah i've actually been talking to like
quite a few gentlemen out there like you
know wondering what their mindset is
as far as seeing the girls what do you
guys view us as
like i i wonder because do you guys
watch our backs when you guys see us and
you start following us saying aaa or
are your instances to rob us i ask
questions most girls are just on this
freelance i'm going to go my parent
wants me to go i'm going to go get it
i'm going to go back
but i have to inquire about my safety
so i'm stopping guys i'm just like dude
you know i'm gonna ask you
are you following me because you're
gonna rob me are you following me
because you're gonna try to hurt me
why are you following me you know are
you an angel in this guy what are you
why
because i've been right here and you're
still coming you know i i'm gonna stop
and if i don't vocalize it then they'll
never know
that i know that they're there so it
kind of keeps people from bothering me
see when you let people know you know
they're around you let them know you
know they're watching they kind of back
off
and i'm sure you're heightened intuition
oh yeah it kicks their butts
it saved your life quite quite often a
lot more now than usual
i've been meditating a lot more lately
so i'm getting more into with myself
what's the most important lesson you've
learned from living this life
don't be so quick to go get money
it's not worth it because at the end of
the day your own pimp will set you up
yeah you go right out there and get in
and already know that
there's someone that's going to pay you
and then somebody's going to get you
and you're going to come home and get
your ass beat or you're not going to
make it home
one of the two
so i'm never ever ever this
blessing safe place you know you can
express yourself
um if people are listening people are
watching somebody might grasp hold to it
but the searches is something else and
people are dying in droves
in droves i mean there's constant
gunshots
people are walking up getting stabbed
you can be walking
it's bad it's really bad
all right beautiful thank you so much
for coming in again thank you for having
me i appreciate your best
hope you have a great year you too